so today I have Dr Kristen seani and Dr
Regina nuto with me Kristen seani is a
professor of epidemiology at Stanford
University she teaches courses in
statistics clinical research and writing
provides statistical support for
clinical studies and writes about
Medicine Science and statistics for a
range of audiences she authored the
Health colum body news for aore magazine
for a decade she's also the statistical
editor for the journal Physical Medicine
Rehabilitation and she co-authors a
statistics column statistically speaking
for this journal she teaches the popular
massive open online course writing in
The Sciences on corsera she was the
recipient of the 2018 biosciences award
for excellence in graduate teaching at
Stanford University and Regina nuto is a
professor of mathematics at gadet
University and lecture in population
Health at Stanford University she
teaches courses in statistics science
writing and data communication for
students clinicians researchers and
other working professionals as a
freelance journalist she's covered
topics in health medicine and research
including preclinical and clinical
research clinical trial design and
research rigor and reproducibility for
Publications such as New York Times Los
Angeles Times cancer today Scientific
American and nature she received the
2014 excellence in statistics reporting
award from the American statistical
Association and she gives workshops
short courses and keynote talks about
statistics research and communication to
audiences worldwide so thank you Kristen
and Regina for being with us today and I
will go ahead and pass it on to them for
their
presentation thanks Jackie so today in
this webinar we're actually going to
discuss four case studies that have
important lessons for the design and
Analysis of clinical trials and they
actually have also some pretty
interesting interventions things like
wine and hookworms and some digital
Health
Products so Regina this first case study
is super interesting because they
actually randomly assign people to drink
wine or mineral water every day for two
years I'm I'm wondering how I can sign
up for this is it too
late um the study came out in 2015 it
did get some headlines in the media as
you can imagine here's one of them here
it was specifically in people with type
2 diabetes and they did claim to find
some health benefits for wine in terms
of cholesterol lipids and insulin
sensitivity which I think is good for
our happy hour tonight
right I totally want wine to be good for
your health absolutely but hold that
thought because we are going to
scrutinize those findings in a minute
here uh I do want to give the authors a
lot of credit though because because as
you can imagine it is not easy to do a
randomized trial of alcohol
drinking you know I think this is super
important Kristen because I see these
types of headlines all the time and
they're observational studies and of
course you can't get causation from
observational studies because here's
where you're observing people who have
already chosen to drink wine or not so
if I'm the sort of person who likes a
nice glass of red wine at the end of the
day I am probably different in other
ways that also affect my health that's
exactly right I mean they've actually
found that wine drinkers tend to be more
educated they tend to have more money
than non-drinkers so how do you know
it's the wine per se versus these other
factors that's influencing their health
that's why you need randomized Trials of
course so let's actually dig into the
study behind the headlines this was
called the Cascade trial it was a phase
three parallel randomized control trial
so phase three means they were looking
at the efficacy of wine parallel means
everybody was assigned to one group and
you stayed in that group the entire two
years of the trial the participants were
224 adults with type two diabetes uh
they were all non-drinkers to start
because they wanted to see the effect of
adding wine to the diet the
interventions were 5 ounces daily of red
wine or 5 ounces daily of white wine for
two years or you could have been put in
the control group which was 5 ounces
daily of mineral water the study did
provide little bottles of water and wine
for the participants it was randomized
so you didn't get to choose which group
you were put in um however it was not
blinded it's kind of hard to do that
yeah you can usually tell if people had
a glass of mine right so hard to Blind
um for the purposes of this discussion
though I'm gonna focus on the outcomes
of this study so I went to the report
which was published in anal of internal
medicine and I extracted all of the
outcomes that the authors reported uh
these were the two-year changes since
Baseline and they labeled five of their
variables as primary outcomes these had
to do do with cholesterol lipids and
insulin sensitivity and they labeled 10
additional variables as secondary
outcomes these were other measures of
insulin sensitivity cholesterol lipids
and things like blood pressure and
weight right so Christian I'm seeing
five than primary outcomes that is a lot
normally we like to see just one or two
right because every time you test a new
outcome you're opening yourself up to
another risk of getting a false positive
there so do they control for that or
adjust for that in their analysis no
they did not do any adjustments to the P
values for multiple testing and the
worry is if you have five primary
outcomes that's going to greatly inflate
your type one error if you don't adjust
the P values um which they did not um it
gets a little worse than this though I
want to give the authors a lot of credit
though because they did did uh
pre-register their study in clinical
trials.gov so pre-registration means
that you publicly release your protocol
before you even start the study and
pre-registration is great because it
kind of locks you into the protocol it
helps researchers to avoid the
Temptation later of just changing
everything in their protocol after they
see the data so super important to
pre-register um that means though that
their protocol is available in clinical
trials.gov anybody can go and check did
they actually stick to their protocol so
I went ahead and did that um
specifically I looked at the outcomes
that they had in clinical trials.gov so
in clinical trials. they said that their
primary outcome measure was going to be
a six-month variable not a two-year and
only one variable like seeit control
which is actually a little vague I think
that might be hemoglobin A1c which was
not one of the primary outcomes they had
in their paper and they only listed one
secondary outcome which was cvd status
which I think is cardiovascular disease
you either have it or you don't a binary
variable so uh no matter what this does
not even match anything at all what you
put on the previous slide right this is
completely different they didn't this is
uh yeah this is let me show you what
that was actually in the published paper
um totally a mismatch right none of
these are the
same so this is actually a practice that
we call outcome
switching um and it's not good um if you
are allowed to choose your outcomes
after you see the data well that's gonna
greatly increase your chance of what we
call a type one error a false positive
error not good
not good and actually let's go a little
further and do a little thought
experiment here Regina so uh we can
imagine if wine does absolutely nothing
if it has absolutely no health benefits
we would actually still expect to see
some statistically significant effects
in a study designed in this way and we
can predict exactly how many so we need
to know that in the Cascade trial they
used a 5% significance level meaning
they would declare results statistically
significant if the P value was less than
0.5 that's very standard but it creates
a 5% type 1 error rate and I'm counting
in the published paper there were at
least 120 hypothesis tests that they ran
so remember five primary 10 secondary
outcomes that's at least 10 variables
they looked at I'm sure they even looked
at things that weren't in the paper but
at least 15 and remember they had to do
two comparisons for every outcome red
wine versus water and then separately
white wine versus water and they
measured everything at four time points
and they analyzed those time points
separately rather than putting them
together in a single repeated measures
model so that's a lot of hypothesis
tests okay so to answer your little pop
quiz for me how many significant results
would we expect first of all you got
that 120 from multiplying 15 * 2 * 4
and0 is a lot of hypothesis tests and
you said that uh the methods would allow
for five% of them to be false positive
so 5% of 120 is six so
right six false positives there we go
right BL do absolutely nothing we're
still expecting to see six statistically
significant results and this is this
idea that if you torture the data long
enough they will confess to anything I
love that quote you know but I think um
sometimes people get maybe a little
confused about how does torturing data
right lead to false positives it sounds
a little strange and I would like to
think of the role of random chance in
all of these measures it plays a big
role and uh like cholesterol level so
every time I go into the doctor my
cholesterol changes just a little bit so
assum wine does nothing but at one of
these time points like um 18 months you
just happen to have in the red wine
group more people that have lower
cholesterol levels so wine does nothing
but it's going to look like it does
something and so that's going to come up
statistically significant as a false
positive
and the whole torturing thing it's like
you know there's going to be a false
positive somewhere so you turn over all
the Rocks right as many as you can until
aha you find six false positives maybe
exactly that's exactly right and uh
Regina you want to take a wild stab at
how many statistically significant
results were in the Cascade paper I am
hoping it's not six please tell me was
actually five and do you want to guess
which five variables specific were
statistically significant there were
five primary variables so I am sadly
assuming it was the primary outcome it
was exactly the primary outcomes three
came out significant for red wine two
for white wine never for both wines at
once and all of the secondary outcomes
were not statistically
significant so Kristen does it look like
to you it looks to me like they
collected a lot of information about a
lot of outcomes a lot of variables good
for them and then ized everything they
could get their hands on and then after
the fact the ones that came up
statistically significant they put over
in primary outcomes they ignored what
they said they were going to do in that
pre-registration um and changed
everything after the fact yeah I mean
there's no way to know for sure what
happened here but it definitely looks
like that's what happened they found all
the significant results and then
selectively reported those as the
primary outcomes we actually call this
practice packing where you're trying to
find significant P values and then
selectively reporting them or
manipulating your data to get
significant P values so um the problem
here is that imagine if you're a reader
of this paper you're gonna look at the
paper and you're going to think the
evidence is stronger than it is because
you're going to assume that those
primary outcomes were picked off priori
now we've looked carefully here and we
know actually they weren't so when I'm
looking at these results in context and
I'm saying okay 120 hypothesis tests
five of those came out significant um to
me this is completely consistent with
chance like in other words I'm looking
at that thinking Yep this is what you'd
see if wine does nothing so to me this
provides no evidence that wine is
beneficial and I'm really sad about that
because I
AB I want wine to be good for my health
but um but there's nothing in here to
convince me this this is what I'd expect
to see if just chances at
work take home points here randomize
Trials of things like wine drinking
super important hard to do but super
important because you can't get cause
out of observational studies but the
more statistical tests you run the
higher the chance of false positives and
this outcome switching this is a form of
pecking or cherry picking that can lead
to false positive
results okay chrisan now this is the
point as we're going to do for all our
conversations about these case studies
is rate the strength of evidence one to
five stars like we are one connoisseurs
ranking a fine wine so what's your
rating yeah Regina I going to be able to
give the evidence here only one star
because like I said to me this evidence
is exactly what I'd expect to see if
wine does nothing so I'm not at all
convinced that wine is helpful for
health sadly yeah so I agree with you
but I'm gonna bump it up to two stars
for me just because I love that they had
the audacity to run a randomized trial
of drinking alcohol drinking wine so two
stars for me fair
enough all right switching over now I'm
going to do case study two Kristen get
ready you gave us drinking wine as uh a
therapy for type two diabetes and I
offer you a maybe more palatable
alternative
hookworms hmms as in parasitic
intestinal infection hookworms on
purpose yes in your body intestinal
worms in your body on purpose yes people
were signing up for this as part of a
clinical trial and as you can imagine uh
the media enjoyed this uh pioneering
trial
it's a study that will make many toes
curl this is definitely making my toes
curl and I think I will stick with the
wine thank you very much and not go with
theork all I ask is that you wait until
you see the evidence all right open mind
open mind going into this so I want to
talk about the details of the study but
before I do that I don't know about you
but I was really curious why are we even
talking about hookworms for insulin
resistance right what is going on there
so I dug into the intros section of the
paper and it was kind of fascinating I
wanted to share this so did you know
that for most of human history they
think that parasitic worm infections
were pretty
commonplace and we just lived with it
and researchers have noticed that in
areas where that is still the case these
types of uh metabolic you know uh uh
lifestyle diseases type 2 diabetes and
other inflammatory diseases they tend to
be lower and then when Public Health uh
workers have gone in and tried to lower
the rate of the parasitic you know
infections they have noticed that those
metabolic disease rates have
risen interesting so that's super
interesting but I'm going to look at
that sort of with the same skeptical eye
as we were talking about observational
studies of wine drinking because this is
obs ational and you know maybe the
places that have a lot of parasitic
worms they also don't have a McDonald's
on every corner and then about the time
people are coming in and eradicating
those worms maybe that's the time at
which the McDonald's are springing up on
every corner so you know this could just
be coincidence right right so uh that is
exactly again why we need randomized
control trials this time with very brave
volunteers who are willing to do this so
let's get into some of the details like
yours this was a 2-year three arm
parallel trial um yours was a phase
three though and this is phase one whenb
and I think sometimes people may not
realize when they see the headlines that
the goal of a phase one trial is very
different than the goal of a phase three
it is not designed to test efficacy it's
not designed to see whether the therapy
is actually working or effective
sometimes they call these phase one
trials uh first inum trials and so the
idea is just get a small group brave
people and see if they can even tolerate
the therapy like what doses can they
tolerate do they have to drop out do
they what side effects do they get then
they use that information to go on and
design these phase two and then
eventually phase three clinical trials
where they can look at efficacy so very
different I just wanted to make that
clear Chris and I also checked of course
to see if the protocol was
pre-registered it was in the Australian
version
of clinical trials.gov um and they
published their protocol in a peerreview
journal and at this they made their data
publicly available so I love that I love
when authors make their data available
because as a reviewer it's very helpful
to me to have access to the data to be
able to check things it also gives me a
lot of confidence in the research
because the researchers were willing to
share their data publicly they don't
have anything to hide I love the
transparency I feel like they get double
bonus points for that one so they looked
at 40 adults who all were at risk for
type two diabetes now 40 Sound small but
it's not unusual for this sort of a
phase one clinical trial and they
randomize them to one of three groups
you could either get a dose of 20
hookworm larvae a dose of 40 hookworm
larvae or a dose of Tabasco
sauce and so the worms are microscopic
The larva
um but they they put it on your arm
underneath like an opaque bandage so you
couldn't see what was going on so the uh
the larvae are absorbed through your
skin that's
gross not don't eat them they go through
the skin yeah are your toes curly now um
yes in the first uh six hours or so they
do come in through your skin and you get
maybe a little bit of a tingling you
know or burning sensation maybe a little
bit of a of a rash there then in case
you didn't know the hookworms kind of
make their way through your system and
eventually arrive at your gut and then
they use their little hookworm heads to
hook on to your intestinal wall um and
that's where they lay eggs and make a
new home for themselves set up a house
so um that sounds gross but um I'm
noticing that that they have a really
nice sham the control condition is a
sham intervention because that chili
pepper sauce that's gonna make you think
you got the worms it's a good Placebo
exactly exactly and they they did tell
them right or you may be feeling a
little bit of a
tingling and I love the Sham
intervention I think is super important
no matter what the intervention but
especially ones that have this sort of
ick Factor right so if you think that
you were randomized into the arm that
has hookworms you might be changing your
behavior right you might like lose your
appetite eat a little less right you
might just feel sck to your stomach just
thinking about it and that's why it was
important to make everyone think that
they might have gotten that intervention
right so then they can separate out what
were participant expectations or or
biases or what were they expecting
unconscious or not and separate out and
really find out what was going on with
the intervention so I love that the
block randomization uh that's nice for a
small clinical trial because it helps
ensure better uh balanced groups and
they did blind the participants uh as we
talked about but also the researchers so
they helped to control for those
unconscious biases or expectations from
the people that were treating the
participants and they were collecting
data from
them nice so here were the outcomes that
they listed in their registered protocol
there were three of them that were
looking at that tolerability and four of
them that were looking at the efficacy
after the fact so Regina we just talked
about in the Cascade trial you know this
kind of a lot of outcomes but actually
this is very different because in a
phase one trial we don't really we're
not worried about type one error because
the point is not to evaluate the
effectiveness of the treatment it's to
just look at safety and and tolerance so
it's okay if you have more outcomes
exactly it's a different different for
that phase one I should say I should say
though even with uh that in their
secondary
outcome they did control for multiple
comparisons wow I'm impressed yeah yeah
I feel like they got they got some extra
points for that one exactly all right so
let's look at what the actual results
were there we go all right serious
Adverse Events there were none they were
a little worried about anemia because
apparently the worms can maybe eat your
blood or something no anemia uh in the
participants but there were some
gastrointestinal side effects in there a
little under half in the hookworm group
none in the placebo not unexpected so
this is when the uh worms are are in
your gut uh so three of it's like loss
of appetite you know nausea so three
participants were not able to take it
they needed to drop out of the study but
the other 24 were fine in fact it went
away it was only in the first month
month and a half um and it went away
without any medical intervention without
any other problems in there Regina I'm
noticing the the other Adverse Events
the non-gastrointestinal um those are
actually pretty similar between the
hookworm and the placebo group which
kind of shows you why you need a placebo
group because um you know people get
headaches things happen you might feel
as you as you mentioned you might feel
icky if you think you have worms so it's
good to know that actually uh that's all
really placebo effect yeah again again
it was really good that they had a good
sham intervention here um they actually
call that nobo effect right a placebo
effect is um you think you might have
the intervention and it might be doing
something good um the nobo is you think
you might have the intervention you
might have um bad side effects um so
they were able to separate that there
right okay um but mood let's look at the
mood the mood was actually slightly
better in the hook one group Kristen and
this was during the
pandemic well I guess they had a friend
they weren't alone during the
pmic little
pet and picture you weren't alone during
the lockdowns right you had someone to
uh play cards with watch TV um the
completion rates were about similar
between the two groups uh so that was
good now again they did not Design This
to look at efficacy but while they were
there of course they looked at it and
they found that the insulin sensitivity
actually did improve in the lowd dose
group that works in the placebo so that
was impressive and the weight look at
the weight the average loss U for people
in the low dose group was about five
kilograms at year one and it persisted
on through year
two kilograms that's over 10 pounds so
that's actually a meaningful amount of
weight loss Regina it is it is and we're
very excited to see this and I think
that might help explain uh my last
observation that all except for one
person everyone else in the hook worm
groups said at the end of the study they
wanted to keep their
hookworms like we're going to let them
live there
forever really I still not convinced
right I'm gonna convince you to come
over team hookworm um I think that this
was great so the the researchers were
very excited about this uh phase one
trial which means now they have
information about tolerability not only
can most people tolerate this therapy
for two years they can even maybe stand
it longer than two years they know what
sorts of side effects to expect and what
the course of that is and they also got
a little information about the dosing um
for some reason it looks like the low
dose better the low dose group did
better than the high dose group and
they're not sure why maybe you just need
20 hookworm larva and not 40 and that's
it so they're going to take all this
information then use it to design a
phase two trial where they'll dig a
little bit deeper into what's going on
with the dose
and then hopefully go on and design a
phase three clinical trial where you can
take a whole bunch of people and see how
the hookworms perform in a big group big
group all right take home points here
phase one trials are not designed to
look at efficacy uh it's the phase three
trials that look at efficacy the phase
one is really looking at tolerability
safety those sorts of things when you
uh make your data publicly available and
when you
pre-register your protocol you make
people happy you really increase your
trustworthiness and doing a good job of
blinding with both the participants and
the researchers in choosing a good sham
intervention will help separate out any
unconscious uh expectations or biases
and let you really focus on what's going
on in the
intervention all right Regina uh how
many stars are we giving that
one um you know I love this it was only
a phase one trial right so they weren't
looking for efficacy but I think they
knocked it out of the park for phase one
for what they set out to do they did a
wonderful job so five stars for
me I'm have to agree with you uh this
was a really well done studay so I'm
gonna have to give it five stars I am
sorely tempted to take away a star for
the ex Factor here but I can't do that
in good conscious because the evidence
is ex yeah I really admire your
adherence to Scientific
principles all right case study Regina
not quite as exciting as hookworms but
um it involves a digital Health product
and the idea here was uh to give people
competition that might motivate them to
engage in healthier
behaviors uh I'm I have to say I'm
pretty competitive so uh this might work
for me yeah me too um it just came out
in 2020 three uh did get some headlines
and they focused actually on medical
interns so um have you ever seen the
show gray an ademy Regina uh yeah a
bunch of beautiful young people uh
overworked right right they're on call
they're sleep deprived somehow the
characters on that show still have
plenty of time for drama but um you know
usually medical interns don't get much
sleep so the researchers here they
wanted to help interns to get more sleep
and more exercise um and so they put
them on teams to Fe and um they engage
them in competition through a an app on
their phone so every week the teams were
randomly assigned to either be in a
competition either for exercise steps or
for Sleep um and they were you
randomized to face off against different
teams or they were randomized to be in
no competition so the intervention here
is being in a competence okay so they
would get a notification of their phone
something like at 900 P.M on Sunday that
would say something like um MGH surgery
faces off against Northwestern Internal
Medicine in this week's step competition
and then they get reminders during the
week uh Yale Psychiatry is leading in
this week's sleep challenge with an
average of eight hours and 41
minutes had way more sleep than I get
what are you talking about I mean yeah I
don't get that much sleep I doubt
interns you but know this was the
example in their paper maybe meant for
illustration of the
notification the app actually looks like
um but let's now dig into the study
behind the headline so this was what we
call a Micro randomized Control trial
and actually micro randomization
something we talk about in our course
Regina super cool new technique that
allows you to randomize people many many
many different times during the study
the um participants were they were in
teams each team had to have at least
five inters there were 191 teams and
they were randomized weekly to either be
in a competition or step or sleep or to
not be in a competition that's the
control here was not blinded because you
did know if you were in a competition or
not um they did give a small monetary
incentive medical interns don't make
much so you know that can often up
participant engagement they had two
primary outcomes so for the comping the
step competition to no competition they
were interested in the average daily
step count as measured by like a
smartwatch and they average count for
the entire team for the Sleep
competition it was the daily sleep
minutes the average daily sleep minutes
was the
outcome talk a little bit more about
that micro randomization the super tool
so in a traditional clinical trial you
can think about something where maybe
they're giving a drug and a placebo pill
it's actually very complicated the
logistics of minimization getting people
the right pill keeping everybody blinded
logistically very
tricky um but if you have an
intervention that can be administered on
the phone like hey you're in a
competition this week guess what the
phone can also do randomization so that
allows you to randomize people lots and
lots of times during the study so mean
week one of this study all the teams
were randomized either to or new
competition and then that was repeated
in week two they were rerandomized and
then it was changed in week three and
you could be in all of the arms at
different times in the study this is
what I love about micro randomization
Kristen so 50% of the time they were
randomized to no competition that means
half of the time each team was serving
as its own control which is very
statistically powerful it's efficient
it's a very efficient use of sample size
because uh especially if you have a lot
of variability between teams so like say
the Stanford team is really good at
sleeping really good at walking around
then you want to be able to compare the
effective competition on top of that
right so it's really helpful when you
have your own control in there yeah
exactly um and just for fun Regina
because I like math uh there are three
arms to this trial and they were
randomized for 12 weeks so 12 different
times that creates three to the 12th or
531 th000 different possible
randomization sequence clearly you need
to implement this on a phone and not
with a person all right they did find a
small but statistically significant
effect uh when they were in the step
competition versus no competition they
walked on average about 100 steps more
per day that is uh walking in the
vending machine Kristen I don't I don't
bite it
you were very sary that could be a
meaningful amount and interestingly when
they dug into the data they noticed
something um they noticed that there was
a significant interaction with time so
the was bigger at the start they were
walking an average of maybe 200 steps
more per day and then it feed off as you
along um you might expect this with
something like a digital ha digital
Health app because you know Board of our
apps on our phone after a
while did not find any significant
effect for either sleep or for their
secondary outcome which was
mood the
um the
uh I was able to check um and the I went
to clinical trials.gov and I was able to
find the the protocol um and I was able
to check their
outcomes I noticed that it was exactly
the same as what they published in their
published paper in n digital medicine so
that was great because there was no
evidence here of outcome
switching but um I did notice two red
flags with this study so um when I went
to clinical trials.gov the stud
completion date was listed at 30th
2021 um and
unfortunately study took place in 2020
but unfortunately they didn't actually
post their protocol to Clinic Tri act
until November 3rd
2021 so they didn't actually
pre-register then this is post
registration not pre-registration right
they're not getting their their benefits
right yeah unfortunately this is
actually not pre-registration so um you
know that's a red flag and then the
other thing I noticed that was uh
worrisome to
me everywhere in the study the protocol
the appendix I thought this was 12we
study when I first read it in fact in
the method section they say we started
on July 6 2020 and ended on September
27th
2020 um that's prob but when I read way
down deep in the fine frint of the
discussion section I noticed this
passage that worried me it says in fact
the data in our study has been collected
for 26 weeks who however we noticed that
the percentage of missing data increased
notably as the study went on therefore
we chose to perform analysis on the
first weeks of the
data um so right so like you are
probably going to say I don't like this
so Kristen it looks like this was
actually what a six month study and
people got maybe bored or you know
participation dropped off so they
decided to just uh only analyze data up
to the 12th week and then get rid of 14
weeks of data and why the 12th week why
not 13th or 11th you know this is this
is another cherry picking this is
another pee hacking uh you probably
don't like it any more than I do yeah I
mean I don't know for sure what happened
here again it wasn't mentioned anywhere
else but to me this sounds like yeah
this was actually a six-month study not
a 12-week study and we can't just change
it after the fact because that's be
hacking and it could have been
transparent here right you can imagine
that they could have just said hey
here's our six months of data they
wouldn't have found an overall
significant effect for St steing they
could have then said but look when we
look carefully at the data we noticed
that there was a significant effect
early on there was an interaction with
time um and uh you know it wouldn't have
really even changeed the take- home
message that much to be transparent here
because small effect early on and it
Peters out because people get bored of
the out so too bad they weren't
transparent yeah take home points uh
micro randomization super cool
technique but free- registration means
free before you enroll the first
participant and throwing out portions of
the data that's another form of pecking
or cherry picking that can lead to false
positives all right what do what do you
say what's our uh five star rating
rating on this yeah so I'm gonna give it
three stars I like the micro
randomization and I also think if they
had been transparent it wouldn't have
completely changed the take-home from
the data so but I got to take some Stars
up for this dumping
data yeah you know I agree with you for
some reason I want to be a little bit uh
a little bit more critical here and
bring it down to two stars just because
they weren't transparent and they could
have been and so that just uh I don't I
don't like that but uh very reasonable
to me Regina right right right okay last
case study I also chose a digital Health
product this one was AI enhanced glasses
for kids on the autism spectrum that
sounds super cool super cool oh it's
based on Google Glass do you remember
this like a decade ago maybe so I
remember there was like all this hype
around Google Glass and then I never
heard about it
again well that's because researchers
are using it now um they realize it
makes a good platform for developing
other you know products or therapies or
interventions this one in particular is
to help kids with autism uh process and
understand emotions on the faces of
people around them um and it's kind of
neat so I want to take a moment to
explain how it works and just because I
was very curious about it so the kid is
wearing uh the superpower glass and it's
connected to an app on their parents
phone and you see in the corner it has a
little prism that's uh like a display
that's where it'll flash things they can
see out the corner of their eye and so
they're interacting with their family
members and then the camera then will
find a face and it spot a face and it
will show up with a little green frame
saying hey there's a face here uh and
then the cool part the app then tries to
categorize that face that faces emotion
into one of emotions happy or sad or me
or something like that then it will
translate that into an emoji that will
show up for the kid so the kid knows
okay this is a happy face and then uh
you can can play games with your family
guess the emotion or tell some jokes and
see if you can get a smile out of that
that's super cool yeah very neat very
neat so they did some exploratory
studies but I want to talk about what
happened with their randomized
controlled trial first of all so the
study Design This was a crossover design
with a weightless control and all that
means is the families were randomized to
either get the intervention first or the
control phase first and then after six
weeks they crossed over so if they had
the intervention first then they went on
to the control phase they had the
control phase then they had the
intervention so every family was in both
the intervention and the control just in
in different orders right depending on
what they were randomized into um this
was registered at clinical trials.gov
but like yours it was only after the
study was completed which I'm noticing
this a lot Regina with digital Health
interventions that you go to clinical
trials deav and you find out actually it
was registered you know right before
they went to publish the paper so I
think people aren't realizing that you
have to register prior to enrolling any
participants not just when you go to
publish the paper so we need to get the
word out about that pre means pre we got
to start a little slogan there um the
data was not publicly available um but
they did say that they would make it
available after the fact for researchers
who would uh sign a release you know
that would contact them directly so they
worked with uh 71 kids all uh with
autism that were already getting
behavioral therapy during the week and
for the intervention they ask the
families to use a superpow glass for
sessions of 20 minutes four times a week
over six weeks and then the children
still got their regular behavioral
therapy um and then for the control
though it was just the regular
behavioral therapy nothing else so
Regina that's kind of interesting
because I'm thinking like the the chili
pepper sauce that there was an
opportunity here to do a better sham
treatment right I mean everybody could
have gotten the glasses and then you
could play a game that had nothing to do
with emotions right so it's too bad that
they didn't use a better sham control
here I know I feel like this is a missed
opportunity because uh before we were
talking about the I factor right with
the hookworms now uh I I feel like maybe
there's a coolness Factor so you're
really excited because you're get into
play with this cool technology I always
get super excited and that might change
your behavior and change the sorts of
things that you're noticing uh so it's
hard to control for those uh those
participant biases or expectations
unconscious they did randomize and they
uh blinded uh only some researchers not
the participants and not all the
researchers so this is what they had
listed on the registered protocol there
were seven outcomes four primary three
secondary and they were all measures of
the kidss ability to socialize or uh you
know decipher emotions sort of thing
some were done by blinded researchers
but some were done by by parents would
worry a little bit about the ones done
by parents Regina because I mean the
parents know if they got the glasses or
not so they could have the expectation
that their kids would do better so I'd
worry a little bit about that and then
I'm noticing here that there are four
primary outcomes it's kind of like the
Cascade trial that's a lot did they
adjust here for multiple testing they
actually did adjust for multiple testing
yes they did B for any correction I know
good for them good for them finally uh
all right so let's see what the outcomes
first one statistically significant that
was the vabs 2 socialization subscale
the next five or not and then the BCC it
was me mentioned in the the registration
and then I couldn't find it in the
actual published paper so not outcome
switching but like outcome losing I
guess the Lost
outcome yeah yeah I'm looking at this
Regina I mean yes that they got one
significant and I guess they did correct
for multiple testing so that's good
there's some control of type on error
but it's not terribly strong the
results yeah um I'm not completely blown
away by this and the more I started
reading the more I found some potential
problems I think that might have
weakened the evidence here U and one we
we touched on a little bit it was the
the
crossover um design and so remember the
crossover design is you just get
randomized one time to either the
intervention then the control uh and
then you flip whatever you know phase
you were in you flipped so with the
micro randomization of course you were
randomized 12 times right so you had
lots of potential things there so these
sorts of crossover designs are really
nice like with your uh competition app
because you get to serve as your own
control but guess what I spotted or
thought of that was different than your
app on this right so so the competition
it makes a good one for a crossover
design because you're you're hoping the
competition Works while you're in a
competition so you're not expecting any
lasting effects it's going to work
during the competition week only I think
the glasses are a little different
though because I assume they wanted to
train the kids in the long run to
recognize emotions so if the glasses
actually work and you get them first you
can imagine there might be some
spillover into the control condition
like you're now a little better at
recognizing emotions so that's gonna
weaken the difference between the
treatment and the control is going to
weaken your effect size yeah yeah I'm
I'm surprised they did this I feel like
this was a missed opportunity and they
might have been better with just a
standard parallel trial where you
randomize into one thing and stay there
yeah so placebo effect issues we touched
on a bit you know even if they didn't
have um the glasses that play at other
sorts of games there they still could
have asked the families okay get
together and tell silly jokes for four
times a week you know for 20 minutes
each H just to have that the family time
control for family timing there so the
last one uh I I think might be
potentially important the families used
the device on average only half as often
as they were supposed to so only an
average of two times per week versus
four and about uh one in four of the
families dropped out because they found
the device too challenging to use or too
uncomfortable this is very problematic
Regina because if the glasses do work
but they're not user friendly if nobody
can use them that's a problem so why
didn't they fix it and make it more user
friendly right especially because as I
said they had done these exploratory
studies before and um in one of them
they also had some uh at 21%
non-compliance rate you know so
something similar so they might have
caught it earlier right right they
should have learned from that
exploratory study why didn't they fix it
after that yeah I know so the problem is
and I double checked this it looks like
the researchers started this clinical
trial while they were still recruiting
for the exploratory study okay wait a
minute so uh exploratory studies the
whole point is to collect information to
inform the design of the clinical trial
but they couldn't have done that here if
they did them simultaneously that
doesn't make any sense bingo bingo I
think they really lost the benefits of
doing that exploratory study so they
were iterating the product throughout
the exploratory study and maybe
throughout the clinical trial um but
they really lost again a lost
opportunity to take the information from
that earlier stage earlier face study
and then design something better there
yeah um so I think overall these
problems my might have contributed to um
them getting some negative comments from
other researchers in the press and uh I
found this quote particularly evocative
it said this is basically science's use
as a marketing exercise
ouch yeah it's it's too bad you know it
really is too bad because I feel like
much of this um was was really um was
really preventable so the the take-home
point
uh here um you really need to uh not
skip steps right if you're going to do
your exploratory study then um make use
of that before you go on to um uh your
later stage trials and that will end up
being stronger as a result really know
your intervention and know the range of
study designs that are possible and then
make sure you choose a study design that
really fits your intervention
and do the same thing with your control
comparison think about what make might
make a good sham intervention or good
control so you can really get a clearer
picture maybe some stronger evidence out
of
this all right Regina so what are we
gonna give this one in terms of our star
rating for evidence what do you what do
you
think you know I'm on the fence here um
I'm going to give it three stars I
wasn't Blown Away by the evidence it did
some good things but I feel like they
had some missed opportunities uh that
they could have done better so I wish
that they had presented some stronger
evidence go with two stars I think
because just I think there was so many
weaknesses in the study design um the
evidence was really not that strong so
starts all right so that wraps that up
uh Kristen as always thank you for all
the scintilating conversation hookworms
and wine and all kinds of good we turn
it back over to Jackie
now and and Jackie will take us y
absolutely um so thank you Christine
Kristen and Regina that was an amazing
presentation really informative we have
a ton of Q&A questions coming in here
and thank you all for sharing your
questions with us we'll try to get to as
many questions as we can a ton of
questions have come in um Kristen and
Regina so we'll um start going through
those here um so the first question that
we have is related to case study number
one so what if the primary outcomes were
correlated based on previous
studies right so um you still need to uh
be judicious in which one you pick now
the idea is if you had you know if they
were so correlated that they are pretty
much the same
measurement right um then you have then
of course it would be like measuring one
thing but presumably cholesterol insulin
sensitivity lipids are not super highly
correlated they may be somewhat
correlated so um so yes if you thought
they were all measuring the same thing
you would still pick one and sometimes
we do things like combine them into one
measure or we pick the one that we think
is the most representative when when
they're highly correlated there's ways
to actually combine those outcomes into
a single measure um if you think they're
going to be highly
correlated especially for the primary
outcomes y yes we're most worried about
the primary outcomes and keeping the
type one error rate low on those yep
okay also related to case study one what
would have been a better statistical
test to prevent false positives with
multiple
testing right so if they were really set
on having five primary outcomes of
course we we believe that actually those
outcomes were chosen after the fact so
both of those pieces are problem not
only having five but choosing them after
the fact but let's say that in the
design of the study they had for some
reason really wanted to have five
separate outcomes then in the design of
the study they should have also built in
some kind of control for multiple
testing Bon fron is the most common
there were actually some more
sophisticated ones that they might have
chosen there but they would have had to
have done that all upfront not after
seeing the
data okay and so I think that kind of
partially answers our next question but
um if you have any additional thoughts
on what um are some of the key steps
that um we need to follow to identify
the statistical false posit false
positives in any research article
instead of kind of blindly believing
it yeah so I mean you you never know
which ones are the false positives or
not you can't know that if we knew that
we wouldn't have to do the study but the
key is um always looking at the totality
of the evidence so authors consciously
or unconsciously are going to try to
draw your eye to the the the few
positive results and you need to step
back and say let me look at the totality
of the evidence so sort of what I was
doing is counting up the number of
hypothesis tests and saying the context
here is we've got at least 120 so you
have to use judgment and just not overly
focusing on the significant ones and
saying well but what was the background
how many did they
test okay anything to add there Regina
nope nope Christian got
it and then also regarding the false
negatives um or false positives how do
how do you mitigate this issue when
you're conducting multiple statistical
tests on a set of data and then will the
adjustments also increase the risk of
false
negatives right good question so um so
the first part you there's a lot of
design traces you have so you can choose
to have only one primary outcome and
then you don't have to adjust your P
values or again if there's some pressing
reason you want to have more than one
then you can use one of these
adjustments for multiple testing so
there's a lot of decisions you can make
in the design phase to try to mitigate
the type one error rate um yeah if you
um if you use these tests for the
multiple testing what you're essentially
doing is making the bar harder right
instead of needing a p of 05 maybe you
need a p of 01 so that absolutely will
increase your false negatives there's
always a trade off between false
negatives and false
positives okay and then the next
question is so is this concept of cherry
picking uh widely known about in the
clinical um industry and they're just
curious how common it is um for clinical
trial results to be
misinterpreted uh no and
yes go ahead Christian you can take that
one I'm GNA let you take that one reget
okay um it's hard for me to it's hard
for us to say what uh is widely known
because of course there are pockets of
people who are doing really great
research right um who know this and
they're doing rigorous research and
they're labed and they're tring out
great researchers but there are a
significant number of people out there
who don't know either they're running it
the trials themselves or they're
analyzing the data or they're
interpreting the results or they're
setting policy or making decisions from
this and well Krist and I addressed you
know some of that in the course um on
what to look for and how to avoid that
so cherry picking is definely one of the
big ones not just in clinical trials but
in science in general yes what was the
second half of the the
question uh the second half of the
question was how common it is that
clinical trial results are
misinterpreted
o again hard to say because I haven't
done an overview of a survey right and
the conservative statistician in meia
doesn't want to go out on a limb and say
something um but I think it's fair to
say based on our Christian and mind
reading of the literature in the media
coverage and the press releases it gets
that there are there are um a lot of
misinterpretations a lot of overhyping
yep
okay and then regarding case study
number two um there was a question about
um explaining the term Block
randomization O good question again
something Chris talk about in our course
I love block randomization because uh
you don't always see the term there uh
it is saying that if I were to just flip
a coin for each person coming in if I
had two arms I don't want to just flip a
coin because by chance Kristen and I
keep talking about things happening by
chance I might end up with everyone is
getting head and everyone in the
hookworm group right and we don't want
that we want to balance it out so you
randomize use a computer to randomize
blocks of six or 10 or 16 at a time and
that way you know that within that block
you will have equal number in the
treatment and the control
group and then what is the formula
that's used to calculate sample size for
RCT and how do we determine primary and
secondary outcomes
so there's formulas um that you can use
um a lot of times if you work with a
statistician they'll actually do a
simulation rather than relying on a
formula so there but there are ways to
to calculate that ahead of time primary
and secondary really just depends on
what is the yeah what is the variable
you think is most important um and
designating that as primary controls the
type one error rate on that variable and
Christian you talk a lot about that in
our course as well what makes a good
primary outcome based on the measures
that you have available and what is
valid and what actually is close enough
to the sorts of things you want to see
yes yeah we do have a a long discussion
of that because you need to make sure
it's something measurable something
that's going to change right something
that's gonna be impacted by the
intervention and and all lots of
considerations
y um and then another question was is
Phase One the same thing as a pilot
study um is
there um uh also talked about in the
course uh these are Loosey Goosey
definitions so Kristen and I you know
statisticians we like things to be
defined and then they mean something
once we started uh you know looking it
means different things to different
people uh if you are uh sometimes FDA
has very particular definitions so you
can go to fda.gov and find out exactly
how they're defining phase one phase two
phase three um but things like pilot or
exploratory study or you know early
stage those sorts of things in the non
FDA regulated sphere are thrown around a
little
bit okay and then regarding case study
number three um was there any way in
this gamification study to control for
cheating so how do we know that the
watch was not put on a spouse or a child
for
instance um interesting one they'd have
to be really engaged to care that much
um I I I didn't see anything in the
protocol that talked about that so I
imagine they were um doing it on good
faith um but you're right they're
they're definitely with the SmartWatches
as ways to to cheat so if they had been
super motivated to beat you know Yale
Psychiatry or whatever it might have
been I suppose they could have cheated
and the because it's measured in um with
a smartwatch it' probably be hard to
tell but yeah I didn't see anything in
the protocol about
that um and then another question is
with such flaws such as cherry picking
how do these um these studies get
published Regina you want to take that
one oh my goodness how do they get
published
um uh some of them not all of them get
published right so we should preface it
that uh it's not all doom and gloom
there is good research that is being
published but you're right there is a
lot of uh cherry pick data out there
that is being published part of the
problem is that I think the incentive
structure right to uh you need to
publish a lot there are people who
really need to publish and uh also the
peerreview system so Christine and I do
statistical peer reviewing but typical
peer reviewers are interested uh they
understand about the content the
medicine of of whatever it is and
they're not looking at the methodology
necessarily so it's very easy for these
sorts of packing things to slide
underneath the radar and if you're very
determined you can hide your packing
from peer reviewers and why we've seen a
lot of scandals come out recently with
researchers who have been caught doing
fraudulent things with data yeah peer
reviewers I mean they're overworked uh
it's volunteer work so sometimes the
quality control is not as good as it
could
be okay and then um another question
here uh based on case study number three
was how should we deal with the drop off
in dedication or participation that we
often see in long-term studies so
another thing we talk about in our
course is participant engagement how do
you keep participants engaged um because
if you have nobody using the app at the
end that really does water down your
results so there's definitely things
that you can plan to try to keep those
participants um engage and it's super
important because you don't want a lot
of missing
data so I know we're coming to the end
here we've gone over a little bit so
just a couple more questions um if we
have time about case study number four
here um we had like I said a lot of Q&A
questions come in um and so the next
question is regarding case study for
what's the difference between micro
randomization and crossover design yeah
yeah good point I tried to address that
a little bit um along the way uh so the
micro randomization is very cool it's a
very new technique as Kristen showed
demonstrated uh you can't do that by
hand if you are going to randomize
everyone to a new either treatment or
control group every day or every week uh
that is not something you do by hand so
the crossover design typically is used
to refer only to you cross over one time
so usually it's something if there are
only uh two arms you know maybe a
treatment a control or at most you know
maybe three arms something like that so
you're crossing over but you're not
during the study being randomized to a
different condition every week or every
day so the micro randomization ends up a
little bit more um difficult to analyze
um uh there are good statistical
techniques for that just because it's a
little bit more complicated but it's
also a little bit more powerful hope
that helped be called a special case of
a crossover study I guess right that's
better that's better
thank okay and last question um the last
question here is what is the most simple
way to differentiate primary objectives
versus secondary objectives
H so I think that's a little bit similar
to the question about primary and
secondary outcomes so um is there is
there a more interesting question right
after that um um there is um there's a
question about how to calculate sample
size for crossover studies and if you
can give more information about
that that will refer you to references
so we're not we won't we won't go
through that on the work with
and then um do you think it's necessary
for journals to amend their guidelines
regarding clinical trials to mandate
pre-registration oh good A lot of them
already do um and so I think this is why
as we were talking about you might see
people registering right before they
publish their paper um because it's a
requirement of many many journals that
you are registered but they may not be
checking carefully to see if it was
actually pre-registration they're just
looking that you have that number so if
a journal editor Reviewer is checking
carefully they should make sure it's
pre-registration but yes a lot of
journals do have that
requirement I've been involved in some
groups and this is actually a big
discussion among researchers and
Publishers because uh some researchers
don't like to be tied down to
pre-registering things they want the
flexibility to analyze things as they
come in um and have some fun and so they
are resisting that and Publishers want
it you know there's that normal tension
there so stay tuned
that has not yet been
resolved great thank you okay I think
that's about all of the questions that
we have time for so thank you for
staying a little bit over here to answer
some of these Q&A
questions um and you know if you'd like
to learn more from Dr siani and Dr nuto
uh we encourage you to join our clinical
trials course so you'll have more than
12 hours of content to learn from them
um access to videos and exercises to
sharpen your skills we also invite you
to um check check out more courses from
our health Innovation um topics so we
have a course in digital Health product
development as well with Dr Bryant Lynn
and Dr Oliver Alami um and other courses
from the Stanford center for health
education so feel free to um visit our
site we'll also be sending out a link to
the recorded webinar within a week um
and so feel free to revisit this content
as well um in the meantime we hope you
have a great day a great week and we
hope to you on future sessions thanks so
much thanks for coming everyone thanks
everyone